that does kind of have a country feel
not to be really needs backup but Blake
Shelton is all about lemonade's country
track daddy lessons and he has a message
for the haters I can't believe what
people that don't contribute to music
that criticize music I just it blows my
mind and Beyonce I tell them to kiss
that ass is what I would do
Okin like Blake Shelton yep we can
always count on Blake to tell us how he
really feels and he had an equally
entertaining take on his future the
voice co-star Miley Cyrus she's very
vegan tree hugger anti-hunting and you
are varied none of those things yeah I
love to hunt um you know but here's the
thing with Molly and I is I've known her
dad for years and years and so it's like
I'm gonna call your dad I will I will
tell your dad for the ask you're being
right now so you better settle down
Missy Miley and I will I don't I can't
imagine us ever having a problem we
completely understand each other and
just because she lives her life one way
and I live my life one way it doesn't
mean you know were not friends
had there been crazy for you to kind of
see her evolution go from you know the
Hannah Montana to the Miley Cyrus that
we know now it's the craziest maybe
evolution ever but I don't know that
she's anybody can say she's made a wrong
move I mean she's one of the biggest
stars in the world and the numbers kind
of speak for herself you know and so you
can't do anything I don't think then
when you look at her career and the
success she's had other than just go
respect respect